foreign
[Music]
[Laughter]
s of the reject Nation did Tarantino
insult Marvel actors that is the
discussion today John how are you I am
Cinema how are you I am also Cinema
ladies and gentlemen I've been seeing
this going around a bunch and I feel
like we can have a really fair open
honest discussion not just turn this
into a big rant video just don't feel
that way about this but I do find it an
interesting discussion to be had
especially because wooden Tarantino one
of my all-time favorite filmmakers love
Marvel as well now my dads are fighting
with each other what's going on here
it's okay the Christmas presents are
going to be that much better if you guys
leave a like that would be very much
appreciated all right so what's
happening today right now is what people
would the main quote that's going around
Taren Tino saying Marvel actors aren't
movie stars when I first heard this my
first thought was I'm sure there's more
of this story
at all over a table Tarantino I said
you're no longer one of my favorite
filmmakers Tarantino I hate you when I
heard this I was like I'm sure there's
more to this context than than just that
because yeah I mean if you just isolate
that that sounds insulting I get how
people can say it's insulting and then
everyone's just having their discussion
and most people go off of one line
instead of bothering to read the
additional context first reaction to
that I feel like there's a lot of
thoughts to sort of you know render from
this one that one statement yeah is like
yeah Tarantino is not right but
tarantine is also right yeah that's like
that's the bottom line I'm not entirely
wrong yeah there's a gray area to to
what he's saying and then sure enough
when you dive into what he actually said
I'm like yeah that's more along the
lines of what I thought he was more than
likely saying so what Tarantino said
part of the marvelization of Hollywood
is you have all these actors who become
famous playing these characters but
they're not movie stars right Captain
America is a star or Thor is the star I
mean I'm not the first person to say
that I think it's been said a zillion
times but it's like you know these these
uh franchise characters that become a
star I'm not even putting them down
frequently to tell you the truth but
that is one of the legacy of the
marvelization of Hollywood Movies oh
right
take your baking soda this morning I did
I did I did what I'm interpreting as
like the gist of it is there was a day
and age when there was a thing called
movie stars meaning where if a person
starred in a film it could really sell
tickets just because that person was in
it whereas something like Marvel they
don't really need a movie star to sell
their films it's like simulio is not
that well known he's like kind of it was
like mid but shanxi can do well I didn't
really know Chadwick Bose and a lot of
people didn't know Chadwick but I was
like they might have been familiar with
some of his other roles but the name
Chadwick Bozeman wasn't in his household
but then everyone knew him from Black
Panther because there's such a thing as
a franchise making a star like that's
why some people take on James Bond to
become an actor to take to have more
roles down the road doesn't always pan
out but that's why sometimes I do it I
wouldn't say the star sells James what
James Bond who sells oh yeah and that's
part of the lore of signing up is you
will now be catapulted to the next
Echelon if you do a good job of actors
exactly the Harry Potter kids none of
them were movie stars like they're not
and that's just part of the way it works
with anything what's based off of a
really popular intellectual property is
usually the intellectual property is the
star and especially if the intellectual
property has a main character that is
the highlight of it all it's like
sometimes the story itself is the big
thing but you will need a movie star to
help sell that but a lot of times it is
just the character and that's part of
what makes comic books so special is the
character so he's not wrong they are the
star of it but I think the way how it's
being taken is that these guys are not
qualitative movie stars I think that's
the way some people are receiving this
they are not great actors they are not
worthy of being movie stars though I
could see the way the responses are and
that's why it's become such a such a
headline these people cast they're not
leads they're not real good leads you
know yeah he's he's poo pooing their
qualities as actors rather than people
realizing that what he's saying is that
the characters maybe it's like the you
see Chris Hemsworth in something and I
feel like a lot of the population is apt
to say oh Thor's in that so like the
characters Legacy follows the actor
around but they still go after movie
star caliber actors people who would be
movie stars people who can open both a
big Blockbuster but who have the chops
to guide an Oscar movie it seems like
Marvel especially has pushed forward the
trend of hiring like the best caliber
actors you can for your giant
Blockbuster property and making movie
stars out of actors who were mostly just
known for their acting prowess before
that and I think you know marvel being
one of the like the most dominant thing
right now in Hollywood it makes sense to
to kind of shine a spotlight on it but
I'm saying what I'm saying in response
to what tarantine is talking about is
like this problem has existed for many
actors before Marvel depending with any
big IP characters you know like Daniel
Radcliffe wanted to break away from that
Robert Pattinson had a hard time
breaking away from the Twilight image
anyone who plays Batman anyone who plays
any popular character that can that can
stick with you and that's why the word
typecasting exists and oftentimes having
to try to get out of a shadow of a
famous character like that's a that's
just a thing that happens you know I'd
also say even though Chris Pratt was
already on the rise of things like Parks
and Rec and other movie appearances safe
to say Star-Lord made him a movie star
and now he's gone on a star and a bunch
of other things he's also like on
certain technicalities he's not entirely
correct like Chris Evans it was pretty
popular beforehand maybe he wasn't like
A-list star but he was pretty famous bit
in the Human Torch already yeah it was
for the two movies sometimes the Marvel
movies and why they weren't the headline
actors uh they would have supporting
actors in them Gwyneth Paltrow
oscar-winning actress Jeff Bridges was
in there Mickey Rourke
but he is a movie star he just came off
the wrestler you know uh Tommy Lee Jones
was in Captain America which I know is
not he's not that famous anymore but
there was a time where he was like a
movie star Anthony Hopkins and Thor then
you look at like Paul Rudd in Ant-Man
not a DiCaprio or a Tom Cruise level but
he was a guy who when they cast him you
were like oh Paul like it wasn't oh wait
a minute to remind myself who Benedict
Cumberbatch is really quick it's like no
everybody knows Paul Rudd it's just this
is a different type of movie than we're
used to seeing him in Angelina Jolie in
eternals I think that's the one you just
really can't argue with oh sure she is a
star Michael Douglas Michael Douglas I
think though that that's a good thing
and I think this is like a it's being
it's being talked about as a negative
thing you know like I love when
Tarantino does get actors like you let's
pair up Brad Pitt and DiCaprio Once Upon
a Time in Hollywood I'm like that's
exciting to me those are two famous
people they're coming together one of
our couple remaining movie stars too I
love that yeah okay those two in a movie
that's awesome like I know that feeling
and no Marvel does not lean into that
just that's just a fact I think the way
it's being taken is this like super
negative thing yeah well I'm like well
no I mean it's it's not even a negative
thing everyone's acting like he just
flat out like I'm putting in the title
of the video because that's how
everyone's taking it but because yeah
he's I don't think he's insulting them I
I'm like this is just a fact of the
situation that when you play characters
this famous oftentimes that character
will follow you around but like
sometimes you can break for Daniel Craig
has got the knives out franchise first
episode
and and yeah and and Chris like various
of the Marvel actors have gone on and
you can still say that Marvel is a big
part of you know their movie stardom but
there are tons and tons of starring
movie roles for them now that their
whole point is to be opened up by the
clout that the actor brings you know you
have like the glut of Chris Hemsworth
Netflix movies and things like that to
look at here part of what is muddying
the conversation of what he's actually
trying to get at is I think it's him
declaring this the marvelization of
Hollywood because I think if you look at
the discussion in a macro sense the
death of the movie star as we know it or
as we have known it for you know the
better part of Hollywood history yeah
that is a real thing but I don't think
it's Marvel at the center of it or
Marvel creating this new trend of oh no
we don't have movie stars anymore we
just have you know the stable of Marvel
actors or something like they're
reaching for people who already are on
the come up and I think that yeah just
the change in the business is across the
board it's not just Marvel movie star is
dying as a breed anyway now they're just
you know kind of synthesizing the new
version of that well I think though that
it wasn't even Marvel that really
started it it's like what people started
craving was to get lost just in the
characters you know I think there is a
part of me that when I go see a Tom
Cruise movie
I kind of want to see Tom Cruise
like that's my association with that is
I want to I don't I'm not really like I
want to only see Maverick on screen I'm
like no I'm aware I'm watching Tom
Cruise but I want to see a good Tom
Cruise hearing it's about it's about
seeing Tom Cruise but with a slightly
different layer at this time yeah
exactly but Will Smith or whoever it is
I feel like when the dawn of of like
true there was like method acting in the
form of like De Niro and Pacino but when
there was the transformative like
consistency of people like Daniel
Day-Lewis and Christian Bale and Gary
Oldman that started changing the tide I
feel in a lot of ways of what is a movie
star because then all the other movie
stars get accused of playing the same
character now yeah and where because now
it's like so much easier it's easier to
do that when they're not really changing
their voice and stuff whereas you got
people like Christian Bale who Christian
Bale's a movie star he's a thoroughly
movie star my point with that is we want
to not see the movie star we want to see
the character only so getting people in
Marvel who are like mid to unknown helps
that whereas like yeah I mean I don't
feel like you really need a movie star
this change started occurring before
Marvel really took off that's what I'm
getting at no 100 I think you're
absolutely right that nowadays we value
a movie star level of Charisma but also
the ability to be a character actor I
think we get much more excited now by
seeing some big name actor we all know
try something different or try something
that surprises us and that naturally I
think takes you away from focusing in on
your innate Charisma and that's the
character and that's the role and yeah I
think you're absolutely right it's been
on a decline and I think you can watch
as several just movie stars careers have
started to take declines over time yeah
and I mean you know I feel like you can
trace those roots back to maybe around
the time Marvel begins to to kick off
but probably before that you know
probably at the turn of the 2000s you
can probably note that's starting to
happen but yeah guys I mean what do you
think about this piece of news do you
agree with Tarantino uh because I I feel
like we had a pretty fair discussion
here but you'll leave me your thoughts
down below uh subscribe click that Bell
leave a like and uh you know look into
full context before you get upset I can
read the article
[Music]